بعد عرض اولى حلقات اثار مسلسل فلوجه جدلا
واسعا العمل يتناول موضوع انحراف
المراهقين في المدارس بتونس لكن
الانتقادات الرئيسيه انه يتعمد التقليل من
قيمه الاستاذ ويروج العنف والتمرد بشكل
متعمد وزير التعليم انتقد العمل ووصفه
بالمهزل كما نشرت الجامعه العامه للتعليم
الثانوي بيانا تدعو فيه لتحقيق مع
المطورطين في منح ترخيص التصوير داخل
مؤسسه تربويه عموميه المزيد في تقرير
كواليس مع الزميله سهى الوعل
ان
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ضجه كبيره بدات مع بدء عرض مسلسل
الفلوجه في تونس ومطالبات بايقاف العمل
ابرزها كانت من وزاره التربيه بمصالح
القانونيه واللي رفعت دعوه تطالب بمراجعه
العمل وحذف مشاهد اعتبرتها مسيئه للمؤسسات
العموميه وللمربين والتلاميذ على حد
السواء كل صدق مكملتوش ما كملتوش على خاطر
انا حسيتو المسلسل هذايا ماهوش
مع كل من
طالب بدعوه الى ايقاف هذا المسد لانه يسيئ
منه ويسيء من شبيبتنا ومن تلاميذه النوبه
المؤسسه التربويه خاصه هو المسلسل فيه
البقعه متاع التونسي راه وفي زاده قلت
احترام على خاطر عبيد في رمضان تجيب حاجات
محترمه تجيب حاجه تعقل التربيه
اي مسلسل اي فيلم يتعدى على هيئه
الرقابه هذيك قبل ما يبدا يخرج للعباد
ممثلين ما شاء الله عليهم اوكي موضوع حساس
اما مش في رمضان هو صحيح اللي يحكيو فيه
اللي يحكيو فيه مانع وكل صاير كله صاير في
تونس بالعكس انا
وتعيش فيه في الحقيقه كامل درامي يوصل
الواقع وصل
المخبي
ة أنا عايشينه
المسلسل يتحدث
عنه
ترويج المخدرات والعلاقات العاطفيه والعنف
ودور رجال الامن فيما يحصل في محيط
المدارس وعلاقه المراهقين باوليائهم
مواضيع اعتبرها البعض ليست جريئه بل
المدعيه الناس الكل في هذا حمات المسؤوليه
للشباب هما بيدهم محمد المسؤوليه للعائلات
قامت المسؤوليه يزيد المؤسسه التربويه
مشيت في جماليه جماليه اللي جملت الواقع
بالحق جملته علي موجود خاطر اللي موجود
اقصى واصعب وامروا خايب اكثر من كيكه اكثر
وسائل التواصل الاج امتلات بردود الفعل ما
بين من يعتبر المحتوى خارج عن المالوف
ويضرب بمظوميه الاخلاق للمجتمع وما بين
مؤيد يراه انتاج قريب من الواقع ويعكس
الصور الحقيقيه للمجتمع دون تزييف ولا
يشكل اي خطر على الشباب الناشئ
[موسيقى]
اكل من
جماعتي
[موسيقى]
على كل من تونس ينضم الينا الممثل ومساعد
المخرج المسرحي محمد علي بن جمعه وهو احد
ابطال هذا العمل اهلا بك يا محمد مرحبا
منورنا في مساء العربيه في رمضان كل عام
وانت بالف خير
مساء النور كل عام وانتم بخير ان شاء الله
اهلا بك انت احد ابطال عمل مسلسل فلوجه هل
كان متوقعا كل هذا الجدل الذي اثاره بين
الاوساط الثقافيه والرسميه في تونس
متوقع لانه الموضوع جريء لكن في الاخر هو
مسلسل هو مسلسل
فني يمكن يحط الاصبع على المشاكل لكن
مايلقاش الحلول المجتمع التونسي يمكن حتى
المجتمعات الاسلاميه العربيه في رمضان
حساسين شويه ما يحبوش يشوفوا اذا مواضيع
يمكن الصادمه
نوعا ما لكن احنا دائما نقول الفنانين
امتى السينمات تدخل للتلفزه
فلوجه المسلسل
سوسن هو مسلسل رائع فنيا فيه اداه فيها في
حركيه فيها قصه جميله لكن الموضوع حل نقاش
في المجتمع وهذه ظاهره صحيه بالنسبه لي
بوجودك معانا اليوم في مسائل عربيه نورتنا
وشرفتنا في هذا المساء هذا اولا واليوم
كمان لماذا يغضب الشارع التونسي من عمل
الدرامي يرصد ويسلط الضوء على حقيقه ما
وان كان يصورها بشكل مبالغ ربما في
المسلسله والعمل والدرامي كنا موجوده يعني
نحن في قناه العربيه وفي النشاط غطينا
اكثر من مره مساله الاضرابات المتكرره
ومساله الازمه التعليميه مؤخره التي تعاني
منها نوعا ما تونس
هي هي المشكله بتاع بالنسبه لي انا متاع
التواصل نتاع ما تمش تواصل بين التلميذ
والاستاذ لكن انا مثلا شخصيتي شخصيه
الامني هذايا يمكن الصعب المتسلط ما هوش
يتناقش بطريقه
علميه وفكيه وطريقه بلطف مع ابنه ابنه يا
اخو العنف هذاك يمشي للشارع
فالحلول اللي نجم نلقاها انا كاب والا انك
مبدع هو هالطاقه هديه اللي في الخرجت في
المجتمع في رمضان ضد المسلسل هالطاقه هذه
من الوزير ومن الامني ومن الاداري يلزم
تتواصل الطاقه هذيا في نقاش ووجود حلول
بكل لطف نتناقش ونلقاو حلول لانه العمل
للفني يقعد خيال لكن في المجتمع نقولو
موجود اذا نجموا نحكيو على عشره في المئه
من وجود مشكله معينه نتاع مخدرات نتاع
امتاع انه انه التلميذ ما عادش يغذر
للاستاذ بالغزل بالنظره اللي تربينا عليها
من زمان فما مشكله الاطفال والمراهقين
عايشين في عالم اخر متوحدين نوعا ما في
التيك توك في الانستغرام عايشين عايشين في
في عالم وحدهم انا حنقول لك الانتقادات
اللي كانت على المسلسل وانت ترد عليها انت
كبطل للمسلسل مثلت دور رجل امن قام بسحب
سلاح و ضد ابنه اللي كان يروج المخدرات في
المنظومه التربويه اعتبر ذلك يعني ليس
ضربا فقط للمنظومه التربويه ولكن ضرب
العلاقات الاجتماعيه في العمق تونس كيف
ترد على من انتقد المشهد
هو هو مشهد في في عنف صح وينجم
يصدم المتفرج لكن ينجم يصير ويصير اكثر من
هكا لكن احنا راني في الحلقات الاولى من
مسلسل باش تكتشفوا اشياء اخرى معناها ندعو
الناس تتفرج في الفلوجه باش يشوفوا وين
زاد المخرجة حاب تهزنا يمكن الحلقات
الاولى الصادمه لكن نرجع لسؤالك المسدس
هذاك هو اله عمل متاعه كان وجد عصاره وضرب
بالعصا
فالعنف الموجود بين الاب والابن والابن
اللي معاش عنده ثقه في الاب نتاعو هذه
مشكله مجتمع نحلوها ونحكيو عليها ونقعد مع
علماء في الاجتماع علماء النفسيين باش
نلقاوا حلول للشيء هذايا لكن ما يلزمش
الشرطي والامني ياخذ في خاطره ويقول لك
انا صورتي تهزت بالمشهد هذا مش معقول لكن
فما امنين
تفضل خلينا كمان نفهم شغله اليوم يعني
للمفارقه من جهه نسمع انتقادات ومطالبات
بايقاف وجدل واسع حول الفلوجه ومن جهه
اخرى في تصريح كل شيء مرخص وحتى من وزاره
التعليم كيف يستقيم هذا الامر
هو هو في ضجه كبيره صارت بالنسبه لي انا
ايجابيه خاطر بعدين باش نلقاو حلول حتى
حلول
امنيه في حكايه المخدرات في حكايه المعاهد
انه يامنوهم اكثر
ومضات تحسيسيه
باش الناس تبعد عن المخدرات نلقاه حلول
احنا الفنانين باش نجموا نعطيو خطاب اخر
اما امل العمل الفني والعمل الدرامي ما
ينجمش يكون هو اشهاريه تحسيسيه ضد
المخدرات هذا مش دوره لكن لكن نسبه
المشاهده نسبه عاليه انا نلقى رسائل من
العالم العربي اصدقائنا من الجزائر معنا
الفيلم المسلسل عاجب فنيا لكن احنا
التوانسه في المجتمع متاعنا غيورين على
على على صورتنا وهذا معقول
متفهم ونتفاهم
احنا نشكرك برشا الممثل ومساعد المخرج
المسرحي محمد علي بن جمعه وجودك معنا
يعيشك تسلم شكرا محمد